every company is different and selling a
business solution to a company that
talks about their relationship with
their customers is tricky and the way we
chose to do it is to basically provide
you know a higher level of obstruction
around the concept of customer journey
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i am
with guy neil paz a silicon valley based
entrepreneur and the ceo of tatango the
leading customer success solution he is
a pioneer in the customer success field
and is well regarded industry speaker
and community contributor guy is also
the author of the definitive guide to
customer success and established the
customer success summit he is passionate
about people and technology and has
dedicated his career to improving the
way in which business is done through
innovation
thank you for coming here guy a quite a
journey in customer success you you've
been a part of some other phenomenal
organizations like gigaspaces and ibm
but you know really you know this the
last 12 years of of
being a market leader in the customer
success industry with thousands of
customers
some of the top companies that are
customer oriented and looking at a
one-stop shop for for customer success
journeys
um pretty phenomenal and especially
given that you know how i i saw the last
few years unfold i've been hearing
customer success more and more about 10
years ago i didn't hear too much about
it
but you already had founded to tango and
so it's a today it's a no-brainer but
what i'm curious about is is more the
beginning of the journey and some of
those some of those insights and
feelings that led you to to embark on
this crazy path and so guy thank you
very much for being here i'm excited to
pick your brain
absolutely sure so the beginning um yeah
so we um
decided we're gonna do something new and
we were exploring kind of key areas and
one of the you know areas that were
exploding was uh sas and subscription
um you know on the heels of aws and so
forth and uh
we've decided that after a few years
many years in the infrastructure
layers let's focus on application and
the area we want to tackle is the new
relationship between
companies and their customers
because it was clear that the recurrent
revenue model subscription up
as you go
and the need to actually host your
service and provide high quality service
delivery
puts a lot of uh you know effort on the
vendor
to create value to their customers yeah
and uh
you know and i remember back in the day
i was talking to one of the you know
previous ceo that i worked for you know
very big company public at the time and
asked them about the need to focus on
customer
delivery value to customers and he said
you know truly it was never our
you know core motivation investment we
made sure that we market and sell and
then support and from that point onwards
it's not our problem it's the customer's
problem
and he thought that this entire business
is
not gonna work because uh of this
mindset but but i thought we thought
that the mindset has to change right
it's you know if you if customer have
such an easy way to
switch to an alternative
it's on the on the vendor to make sure
that
the reason in which they sign up in the
first place is being delivered so value
is being delivered so that's the
initial thinking of customer success
so so the the the change here or what
i'm understanding is that if before we
were at a time where compa where very
few companies were able to provide a
solution for a given problem and
therefore once they market and sell it's
sort of on the customer's burden to
figure out how to use and how to retain
themselves right it happened naturally
today with and with you know various
competitors in every domain and various
solutions for every problem
now is where the customer success really
kicks in in these last 10 15 years where
you actually have to
to to keep selling them even once
they're already sold
yeah absolutely so they just got to
remember
back in the days
uh it was very expensive to buy software
right an implementation took a very long
time so
yeah the main the main decision was the
purchasing decision now that it's very
you know relatively inexpensive both to
buy and implement um
it's the the power shifted dramatically
to the heads of the
of the customer subscription as well is
a business model
that
provides more value to the customer than
to the company because back back in the
day the company would collect all the
money up front now
you're gonna work for your money uh over
time so
that creates a whole different dynamics
that requires companies to think
differently it forces companies to think
customers first right so outside it
versus
inside out
um and that leads to a whole host of uh
challenges that this what we set up to
uh to solve for companies and so as
you're building out to tango and you're
and i'm looking you know 30 000 feet at
this
at this challenge you know that you want
to sell you want you know that you want
to solve this issue for customer success
you know that you want to solve for
customer journeys and to bring all these
thousands of solutions to the modern
world where they're retaining customers
through data-driven decisions
how do you pinpoint exactly how to do
that because it's a there's a wide range
of tools that you can provide them
at the end you do end up providing a
generalized tool that that encompasses a
lot of their needs but
how do you sort of
pick and choose which ones
yeah so our core
uh you know while competitors looked at
the problem differently our core was the
challenge is the relationship right
where you have to deliver value but the
advantage is that once everything moves
to the cloud you've got tons of
information about your customers so
you're not flying blind anymore you can
really understand who's using your
product how they're using which features
they're using so you can always identify
where is the value being delivered and
what are the gaps and drive decisions
based on that so that was the core
thinking and we actually started with uh
proc instrumentation technology where we
collect uh usage data through
javascripts or apis and so forth to
actually build up
a whole data driven profile of the users
and the companies that they worked for
and from that point onward so so we
thought that the
the challenge is better understanding of
customers to deliver value but the
advantage the opportunity in the
transition to cloud that it's all
connected and everything that customers
do
the company can actually see right if
you uh properly instrument that and sure
then you can make decisions based on
that so that was the the core
principle and the idea which we is still
true to to this day
now as you
build that exact thing out and i'm just
trying to to to reiterate on that you're
saying
companies are moving to the cloud
therefore a lot of the data that they're
collecting if before was on premise now
it's a little bit more accessible
still they may not be aware that they
can then leverage this data in-house to
create teams to
analyze this data synthesize it and come
up with actionable items and therefore
there's a gap in the market where you
can build a solution that takes in this
data even helps them collect it and
provides them with actionable insights
right this was sort of the thesis of
where the market is at yes and i think
very quickly we realized that uh the
path of attack to this market that go to
market is through the revenue and not
through the workflow the capabilities
right because everyone that runs today
it's like a no-brainer everyone that
runs a recurring revenue or recurring
model knows that you have like run
revenue stream which is you know the new
customers and then you've got the
retention of how much have you been able
to keep and then the expansion right so
you're basically three uh components of
revenue and two of them are being uh you
know addressed by the tango and customer
success retaining customers and then
growing existing customers what is now
known as net revenue retention where you
actually measure out of the customer
base at the end of the period
how much did you grow or shrink right
and companies that shrink that's
it's a leaky bucket and companies that
actually take the existing customers to
grow the value for them
they are very good businesses
because they're not only growing by
spending marketing dollars and sales
dollars on new business they can
actually work with their customers drive
more value sell than more
you know
depending on the model more capacity or
more products and and so forth and so
forth so that was the
so it was a very kind of a business
conversation that you could have had and
now the where the market is right now it
shifted into okay so how do i start what
do i do first and right how should i how
do i how should i think about this this
is where we are right now so if your
point a decade ago was what are you
talking about what is it
what why are you calling me to uh
where do we start and uh how to uh what
to do first and and where to get value
from so
um
so it was obvious that this is gonna
happen you know clearly as a
you know we would have wanted it to
happen faster but we're uh very grateful
that it actually happened and we were in
the
right uh we had the solution in the
market right point in time uh to be able
to take advantage of the market
transformation i mean i think that's at
the end you know what exactly why why i
love doing this show you know it's about
these ideas that emerge out of uh
out of some understanding of what's
happening in the market taking the sleep
of faith working for years and what it
sounds to me like you're saying is that
you know perhaps the timing um
could have been
a little bit more
on point and solidified but but perhaps
not and perhaps the this this is exactly
how how things should have played out
and uh and i think it's at the end what
counts is obviously this idea that the
market is ready everybody's talking
about customer success and your position
is a market leader to to win this and
and this is because you've you've also
gained this understanding over a series
of years if we're fast forwarding to
today though you have thousands of
customers the biggest companies in the
world the most customer centric
companies in the world you're no longer
a startup it's a it's a company
and
how do you manage
you know working with thousands of
clients
each of them unique each of them
thinking through their customers in a
different way each of them want their
own differentiation
how do you even cope with that as a
company as a service company
yeah uh as a technology company but uh
it's logical i mean that's but
no no you're actually making a very good
point uh software as a service are you a
software company or a services company
and so forth and we chose to be a
software company right like a hundred
percent our gross margin is close to
eighty percent
uh which means that we barely sell
services right and what you're you're
making a very good point because
you know every company is different and
selling a business solution to a company
that talks about their relationship with
their customers is tricky and the way we
chose to do it is to basically provide
you know a higher level of obstruction
around the concept of customer journey
right so we've we've although every
company is different every company once
it sells its customers wants to onboard
it quickly on their platform and then
they want to make sure that they're
getting value
by looking at the
product adoption and they don't want to
detect risks ahead of time and and take
action on that and they want to maximize
renewal so we've created
this new concept called
um
modularity around around customer
success uh where we have modules we call
them success blocks that allows
companies to start
in one what one point in time right on
on their journey secondly we've built
all those uh success blocks we've built
uh we've we've added a lot of best
practices and templates and things that
allow people to get started very very
quickly so these are think about them as
best practices and examples where
companies can actually learn from what
others have been doing and then
customize this to their need very very
quickly and the last point we chose
um to
to roll this out in a self-service model
all right so tatango is so as of 2020 we
are a self-service uh business with uh
freemium business models and we are
basically solving the learning gap where
people need to understand what it is how
to get started and so forth by giving
free access to all of that all the
platform and the technology and the and
the success blocks for people to quickly
uh learn
and and then once they learn we can have
a much
more meaningful conversation
in which in many cases customers already
know
what is common right what's best
practices industry and what is the
customization they need to do to their
uh to their business and obviously we
will help them to do that as well um but
i think it's you know i've been an
architect before uh so this is like
where where do you put the abstraction
is the abstraction the the functions the
tooling or the abstraction is
the outcome
and all of that together we are you know
calling this week of uh
announcing this concept of composable
customer success so to solve the
challenge of where to get started you
need composable customer success that
allows you to get day one value
allows you to continuously recalibrate
your processes
and um ensures that that's our
commitment uh predictable growth that's
the that's the that's the motivation i
think this is where the market is right
now if we could have dive a little
deeper
but but the way to solve it is to
simplify right to make it
very accessible one of the things that
we've been talking a lot
we don't want customers to learn our
language
we should uh operate in the business
language right so all the objects into
tag all the language is business
language and not you know customer
success language because they will learn
customer success over time but we don't
want them to
to be forced to do it because it slows
down
sales
and so if you're so what you're saying
is if you're looking at this pyramid
where the top of the pyramid is sort of
this this very fine-tuned customer
success journey for your own company
what you've realized is that in order
for anybody to get there first you need
to have this common foundation this
common base
this the these build this big building
blocks of customers customer journey
steps and you're first allowing
companies to make sure that they're
harnessing those steps and they have
visibility
into what's happening in those journeys
and then through composability and
modularity you're allowing them to
customize okay how do i want my customer
success journey to look like and how do
i how do i analyze it and how do i make
sure that it's working properly right
yeah i i i think the the you know when
we look at our markets options right
customer options you've got companies
that come up with their own like a big
bank model and that's a challenge
because they need to adapt their
business to this structure you know it
may work but it's
it takes a very long time requires
constant consulting and services and so
forth the other approach is you have
like just point solutions right so yeah
you know so the customer needs to
continuously integrate between
solutions and there's the other approach
where we build our product as proposable
so you've got modules and they're
pre-integrated they're they're built on
the same data model the same
workflow model and and so forth and
that's
it and we did this not just because it's
a good architecture concept it's also
because
we wanted to reduce the barrier to entry
for a company any size in customer
success so if your only problem right
now is you see it is on boarding new
customers okay let's just focus on
onboarding first if your only problem is
driving adoption let's focus just on
driving adoption to your
product we don't force companies to make
big decisions and by the way when
companies become bigger they're not
necessarily managed managing the entire
journey in one team right so you have
services team that's doing onboarding
and you've got renewal team which is
part of the sales and they're reporting
to the cro while the customer success
team reports to the chief customer
officer and so forth so
this flexibility
allows for companies to kind of reduces
barriers for companies to adopt you know
to get started and then learn that
actually customer success is about the
customer and about the journey so it's
not about the function it's actually a
consistent predictable
uh good user experience and so forth but
but you know when you are a technology
company like ours you got to be
practical it's not enough that the
concept is
good and true you actually need to sell
technology to someone so you got to make
it uh super practical to
wrap their heads around it get started
see immediate value
get uh recognized by their company get
recognized by by their customers and
then
you know take another step from there
has this world
or the the thinking process behind your
own
customer journey thesis has this evolved
much
in the last few years i mean as as
you're building the found the foundation
blocks for for what it means to monitor
customer success journeys or design them
have has your sort of thesis shifted
in one way or another
um yes and the main reason is
i mean i can give you a story right so
we built this concept called uh
success block marketplace now it's
renamed to churning marketplace in which
we published all the known
uh customer success blogs right that
we've we've created
and but but the issue was when when you
would ask people around our company like
people from the onboarding team or the
customer success team or even product
team
so what is what is renewal to you what
what what needs to happen in renewal you
get like five different answers one is
going to focus on the automation renewal
one is focused on the predictability of
renewal one is about the forecasting on
renewal so
it was clear that you gotta create like
a common language first and foremost
right we call this successful master
it's like an internal
document in which we can write
specifically who should use it what what
what should be the expected outcome what
are the metrics and so forth and so
forth so what i learned
is
and that was always like the challenge
in our market that customer success is
many things to many people
and it and it makes it i mean the
outcome is good everyone wants to retain
customers and to grow
their customer base and and to you know
and have all all users as facts right
that's the that's the ultimate outcome
of that and there's the financial
outcome of that and so forth
but what does it mean how to do it and
so forth there's so many flavors
that we had to kind of create at least a
common language i'm not even saying
standardizing because everyone can
choose you know a flavor that is best
for their model
and their business you know some
companies their product is super sticky
so you know it's not about retention
it's about maximizing expansion some
companies their product is in a highly
competitive market and it's a really
inexpensive product like you know
how many
how many design tools are used in in
every company in our company i think
we've got like at least 15 design
different design tools
um that someone is paying a license for
and at some point someone's going to try
to consolidate and 14 of them are gonna
you know um
get out of uh our business so so the
point being there's different challenges
to different uh two different business
models
um
but you asked how how things have
changed is me to realize that if we are
not
specifying
in a more
easy language to understand what is it
that you're trying to do and how you do
it uh it becomes very tricky for people
to communicate so even the customer
success communication language and
is is a is a very important thing so i
you know i had my own version i thought
that's the right version so
i love it guys there's so many more
questions are coming up but
unfortunately it is a
20 minute leaders but but definitely my
curiosity was sparked and so i i really
i appreciate your time and and this
amazing journey and
looking back i'm trying to to look back
at how you were thinking 10 12 years ago
how you were thinking about customer
success and you're thinking about the
movement to the cloud and the transition
to data-driven decisions and the ability
to automate things and have them
then be modular and composable and
customizable and and ultimately gaining
the trust of thousands of brands to
to trust you to help them understand
their customers better and their and the
customer journeys better and i think
that
it speaks for itself and so thank you
very much for the time and the
inspiration uh best of luck with the
rest of the the hopefully long journey
of tatango and and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you very much thanks for
having me
thank you
[Music]